oh
[Musique]
alors là on arrive à l'entrée de la
forêt des mousseuse comment s'est
constitué cet écosystème à l'époque de
louis philippe qui est propriétaire du
château de la ferté vidame il ya un
système de drainage qui a été mis en
place pour assécher cette partie de la
forêt il me semblerait que cela n'ait
pas fonctionné
donc en fait l'eau lolo a stagné et tout
un cortège le végétal et animal donc
s'est installé en ces lieux
à
[Musique]
et porte bien son nom quand même la
forêt ddaf personne de nous donc les six
en fait on a un style qui est une housse
assez typique de ceux de ce genre de
mise le vide ça filtre l'eau l'eau ici
est extrêmement acide
on dit que c'est un milieu oligo trop ce
don qui est peu minéralisée en fait donc
c'est une véritable un véritable château
d'eau quel est ce que le changement de
climat affecte la nature de la forêt
niveau supposé que le changement
climatique fra à à modifier ce genre de
milieu de milieux humides s'aperçoit
depuis quelques années effectivement que
les étés sont beaucoup plus sec donc
vous avez pu le voir les saigne du coup
gorge - moins d'eau sont beaucoup plus
sèche donc c'est vrai qu'en hiver c'est
différent mais on peut supposer que le
climat s'il continue à changer
l'augmentation de la température peut
effectivement affecté ce type de milieu
naturel
donc faut en profiter maintenant faut en
profiter maintenant profiter des milieux
humides de en général et surtout les
préserver c'est c'est extrêmement
important de préserver ce type de milieu
mais
lui